[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a chilean drama thriller film
called jailbreak pact
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the movie is based on a real event that
happened around the 1990s in chile
during the last years of the military
regime many protesters are imprisoned in
a penitentiary in santiago the police
treat them as terrorists and manhandle
them to the cells the general in command
andrade is a cruel man who wants to
teach the prisoners a lesson inspector
braglio gathers them to give them an
introduction to the life they are going
to live from now on since their
imprisonment falls under anti-terrorist
law they will be monitored 24 7 and if
found spreading any kind of propaganda
they will be sentenced to death a group
of five protesters led by leon is also
among the prisoners they have come to
the prison with the intention of
escaping today is the day they choose
their cells and the day they initiate
their plan leon quickly runs to the
second floor to take cell number 50.
according to their plan it directly
connects to the cell below which will be
the opening of the tunnel however he
sees that cell 50 is already taken and
has to settle for 51. the room will be
at an angle this way but the group has
other things to worry about at the
moment the prisoners settle into their
new lives some taking up hobbies like
carpeting cooking singing and so on
during an hour-long break time leon
raphael and germaine discuss the plan
leon is an architect and the mastermind
of the mission he knows that some meters
away from the wall is the mapocho river
surrounded by palm trees the distance of
the tunnel can be calculated in terms of
their steps with every two steps
counting up to five feet this means the
tunnel should be around 70 meters long
they will have to remove around 60 tons
of soil to dig a tunnel of such a length
but the question remains where can they
put all that soil without the guards
noticing as the trio discusses the plan
a fellow prisoner paolo watches them
later he approaches rafael and asks to
be involved in whatever they're trying
to do the trio trusts him and includes
him in the group in the following scene
they are in the ground floor cell which
is supposed to be the opening of the
tunnel they have to make a hole in the
wall and create a block out of the
residue that way they can hide the hole
using the block when they aren't working
then leon looks for a place to hide the
tons of soil a guitarist gets a hint of
this and offers him a screwdriver he is
also included in the plan after that
using the tool leon tries making a
square hole in the ceiling in the next
few days they have to keep the banging
as low as possible even though the
guitarist is outside singing songs to
cut the noise with the last hit two
blocks of cement fall from the ceiling
and make a mess leon quickly asks the
others to bring eggs and lime to make a
mixture that will look like a block and
close the hole the team divides the task
and gets to work but just then the
guitarist sings a specific song
indicating that the guards are doing a
surprise check leon checks the hole and
is satisfied to see that the loft area
is enough to hold any amount of soil
after that he makes the block just in
time and covers it with the poster of a
woman when the guards check the room
they do not think much of the posters
one guard tries taking it off but stops
because the girl is wearing too many
clothes in his opinion it has now been
34 days since the prisoners got to the
prison it is also a visitor's day where
their relatives get to come and meet
them for some time rafael gets to spend
time with his wife but they get into an
argument because she didn't bring the
kids following the meeting the group
continues making a better block that
won't be suspicious even if the guards
get a view of it they do this by filling
a hollow box of wood with cement when
the block is ready they start hammering
the wall that is supposed to be the
opening of the tunnel the cell is filled
with residue cement when they are
informed of the inspector's arrival they
quickly clean up the mess and pretend to
be working fortunately for them the
guard doesn't look around before walking
away to ensure safety leon blasts a
radio and continues hammering the wall
after it is big enough they fit the
block inside and make it look seamless
the remainder of the soil residue is
packed in a bag and taken to cell number
51 there leon puts it on the loft over
the ceiling hiding it where the guards
would never think to look this goes on
for the next few days the guitarist
always waits outside the cell to keep an
eye on who comes and goes the other four
take turns digging the tunnel the soil
residue is put into different bags on
different days to be taken to the upper
floor and dumped on the loft then the
cement blocks are used to close both the
holes and keep them hidden the group
maintains enough social presence so they
don't seem suspicious still a smart
prisoner named oscar sees that they
follow the same routine every day in a
way that seems unnatural to him on day
77 leon measures the length of the
tunnel they have dug until now he is
disappointed to see that it is not
enough at all at this rate they will
take years to complete the task which
means more opportunities for the guards
to catch them leon registers that they
are lacking manpower later that day
german is doing the daily chore of
bringing soil to the upper floor but
this time he is stopped by a guard and
asked to show what is in the bag he
nervously does so but the soil is in the
lower compartment covered by his
personal belongings the guard asks him
to come to the office and jermaine puts
the bag away before following the orders
upon reaching the office the guard
offers him nude magazines for money
german's size with relief and is glad
that the meeting wasn't about something
else in the following scene the trio
continues to dig the tunnel while
listening to the news on the radio they
find out that the people of chile have
completely overthrown the dictator and
have welcomed democracy into the country
it is bad news for them because they do
not believe in democracy the news only
makes them want to work harder so they
can go outside quickly and turn
everything around before their leader
gives up on day 86 leon gathers up the
prisoners who are waiting for the death
penalty he shows them the progress
they've made on the tunnel before
telling them every detail of the plan
the group instantly decides to help them
and is added to the team working at
night is not feasible because of the
noise so they start working two hour
shifts per person during the day they
take the smallest measures to ensure
they aren't caught for instance washing
the dirt off their hands and bodies
after every shift some of them are
always outside the cells keeping an eye
out for the guards and anyone who might
suspect them they also create another
hole between the ground floor and the
first floor so they won't have to
transfer the dirt by stairs which is
much riskier eventually the rate of
progress accelerates and the end seems
near throughout everything the group
continues socializing with the other
prisoners they play during break times
and watch tv as usual to ensure no one
suspects them in one of the football
matches oscar tells raphael that he
knows what they are up to he also wants
to be a part of the team but rumor has
it that he is in prison after snitching
on his own people still leon decides to
give him a chance and includes him in
the mission you know what they say
snitches dig ditches in the next scene
german tells raphael that even if they
make the perfect tunnel without help
from the outside they will never be able
to escape some of their fellow
protesters from the party are still
outside if the prisoners are able to
send them a message they will surely
come to help on day 182 raphael's wife
comes to see him for visitors day he
tells her about their plan and asks her
to inform the party about it the woman
thinks about it for a long time even
after the meeting then comes day 205
work is going as usual and the guitarist
is in the tunnel all of a sudden the
entire police force comes for a surprise
check leon quickly alerts everyone but
it will take more than 10 minutes to
clean up the mess and bring the
guitarist out while some people help him
the others go outside to stop the police
raphael insults them and starts a fight
between the two parties this gives the
guitarist enough time to come out and
seal the opening when he opens the door
the police have already defeated the
prisoners and taken them to the ground
commander andrade makes them stay under
the sun with no clothes getting a naked
tan is hardly punishment somewhere else
raphael's wife goes to the party's
headquarters but she is asked to forget
about the party helping them because
they have enough problems on their plate
however she doesn't give up and thinks
of a better plan she goes to a church to
meet leon's father jermaine's wife and
raphael's old associate they all agree
to help the guys from outside with
whatever they need the scene cuts to day
392 a man is working inside the tunnel
when he passes out fortunately for him
his friend immediately drags him outside
by now the tunnel runs deep and there is
a scarcity of oxygen inside to solve the
problem they include the carpenter in
the team he creates a tube and a
fan-like structure that can supply air
to the deepest corners of the tunnel
then we are introduced to a sly man
named bigote he is called by the
commander and is given a packet of
cigarettes in exchange the commander
wants to know what every single prisoner
is up to later that day raphael finds
out the tunnel has crossed the prison's
border he creates a hole on the ground
and pushes a pink liquid outside it is
spotted by raphael's associate who is
helping him escape on the next visitor's
day leon's father comes to him and
reveals that the liquid is still 40
meters away from the place they want the
tunnel to end on day
558 the city is hit by an earthquake
leon who is outside immediately rushes
in to save the person inside the tunnel
luckily no one is injured and the tunnel
isn't blocked either leon has grown a
friendship with a wheelchair-bound
prisoner over the months he tells the
man about the escape plan and asks him
to join the guy refuses because he has
already given up on life and knows that
he cannot crawl through the tunnel then
finally comes the day they execute the
last stage of the months-long plan
everyone is in the tv room for weekly
nighttime entertainment when one after
another the people start to leave no one
suspects anything because the show is
not interesting leon is outside the
opening of the tunnel checking if all
the prisoners have come there are 50 of
them in total which means they have to
trust each other on who gets to go after
who meanwhile bigote notices the absence
of the prisoners and goes out to check
on them the wheelchair guy tries to stop
him but is shoved when bogota reaches
the cell everyone has entered the tunnel
except for oscar begotte wants to tell
the police but oscar restrains him he is
stabbed with a screwdriver but even
after that he knocks bigote out but then
the injury prevents him from getting
inside the tunnel after the others you
know what they say snitches get stabbed
with screwdrivers the remaining 49 men
are lined up inside the tunnel waiting
for the people from outside to open the
other end raphael's friend does so and
they come outside one after another
raphael's wife has already prepared a
change of clothes for all of them after
changing they hide by the river until a
bus arrives to pick them up they
immediately board the bus but your man
is worried about oscar he asks them to
wait for a while and goes to fetch him
what a dumb idea back in the prison the
rest of the criminals find out about the
tunnel and enter it the police
reinforcements arrive and gather the
remaining prisoners in the bus the siren
is heard so they decide to drive away
without german and oscar seconds later
germain arrives and says that oscar
never came out of the tunnel because
they cannot return to check on him they
simply drive away meanwhile some other
prisoners are able to escape but most of
them are dragged out of the tunnel we
see oscar crying in jail and cursing his
fate the commander gets the news and
loses his mind on the bus all the
escapees are given money and fake ids
following that they are dropped in
different parts of another city in
groups of three in the end leon wishes
raphael goodbye and walks away to start
a new chapter of his life this is how 49
prisoners escaped a heavily guarded
prison after 18 months of digging in
1990. subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching